try and imagine that you're in a phone
box next to the empire state building
and then
the atlantic ocean sweeps in then all
the lights go out then you start
bleeding oxygen then you
know that rescue is at least two days
away
and what you've got to do is preserve
your oxygen as long as you can
stephen mcginty welcome to the show
thanks for having me
we are talking about the world's deepest
submarine rescue
today yes indeed yes indeed it's the
subject of my new book the dive which is
the untold story of the world's deepest
submarine rescue
and yeah it's an it's an incredible
story from a kind of
from the analog age of 1973
um it's yeah but the i mean the the
background to it
um is effectively that um it's just
to get people kind of in the mood it's
really from the time when
in 1973 when um new phone lines were
laid down
and there was what's known as the cantat
um cable was laid
between canada and the united kingdom
and this was this was high technology
you know this was a cable that allowed
1750 phone calls to be made from the
entirety of america
and canada to the uk at any one time
so this was the days when it would be
like three pounds 50 a minute
to make a phone call transatlantic um
but this was the cable
in fact this new cable was three times
what previous cables had done
um and and what what was happening at
the time was that the cable had been
laid
um but these miniature submarines this
pisces three
and was being sent down to do a simple
but very important job
which was um to find the cable and to
dig a little ditch
so that the cable would then settle into
the ditch and then be covered over by
sand and silt
the idea being that while it was on the
surface i mean this was
um 150 miles off the coast of cork so it
was
it was in the atlantic ocean and but it
was still in an area where people were
fishing
and the fear was that um
nets would be would go down or trawlers
and effectively the cable could be
hauled back up
and as i said in the book you know
murphy's law does apply um within 150
miles of ireland
and the fear was that they could they
obviously needed to tackle that
so on the day back in august 1973
there was two men in this this small
pisces three
uh mini submersible there was um roger
chapman and there was roger mallinson
uh roger chapman was ex-royal navy he
was an ex-nuclear submariner um who'd
been
effectively had to leave the services
because his eyesight wasn't as good as
it
should have been and he moved into the
into the private sector
and at the time um what was interesting
about it was
it was the company that ran the
submarines was vicar's oceanics
and vickers is anyone from barrow and
foreign
nautical history of britain will know
vickers was the the titan of
shipbuilders and particularly um you
know military and
naval ships um from the the first world
war
second world war into the cold war um so
what they did was that they were dogs
they making these massive ships but they
decided that
uh it was 1973 there had been the boom
in the north sea oil industry
and they decided miniature submarines
were going to be
an effective gadget effectively that the
industry would have been needed
and this little miniature submarine had
been invented
by these these incredible canadians and
there was a guy called al treice
and al trace back in the 19th earl 1960s
was
from vancouver and he was one of the
pioneers of of he was a great salvage
diver those were the days where you wore
hard hats you went down with kind of
heavy steel boots
and he pioneered some of the deepest
dives i mean they were doing bounce
dives in those days so that basically
meant that you would
you would go down as many as as deep as
maybe 350 feet
but you could be down there for
literally two or three minutes and then
you would take these long
slow ascends to the surface to avoid the
bends
i'll try said look this isn't
there has to be a practical device it
has to be let's let's develop a
submarine
that is small that's commercial and the
french had developed the bathyscope
which had gone down right down to the
cana marinara trench effectively
and but he wanted to develop
effectively a commercial submarine and
these guys who could go into the story
later on the effect of what they did was
they developed they spent their money
they they pioneered and created the
pisces
um craft and what was interesting about
pisces
um miniature submarine was that they
tested in vancouver
on a day that the u.s navy were testing
anti-submarine missiles and what i find
fascinating about pisces that the pisces
graph was that
that um they might it might on its test
dive it might surveyed a missile that
had been sent out
with whose principal job was effectively
to track down
um submarines and there's something
about it that says that this thing was
was maybe indestructible but also lucky
um
so talk us through the craft what's uh
pisces three how big is it inside what
is it
well well the way i the way i could and
when i told people about this this
this book was was essentially to try and
imagine
um that you are you and your friend are
in a large phone box
that's the way to think of it and the
way that i kind of sold it to people was
imagine that you're in a small you're in
a phone box
and the phone box is sitting slap bang
next to the empire state building
and then you watch as the atlantic ocean
rolls in
to a height 10 stories above the top of
the
the empire state building and so that's
the kind of
i mean the size of it was was pretty
compact so five or six feet in diameter
um but you know enough to move around
and but
you know you go you go up you got pretty
close all right so
set the scene we're on the day of this
occurring and what
what's roger and roger doing and why how
do they get down there
well what they what they do so um on the
surface
was at the the kind of the mother ship
which is effectively converted a large
converted trawler called
um the vicar voyager and so that was on
the surface and that was um
that was operating at 24 hours a day the
pisces
um submarine was on deck and they round
about
one and one o'clock in the morning and
they
climbed into the submarine um it was
winched over the edge
it was then dropped down into the water
then it was towed out to a certain point
and what was interesting at the time was
that what they would do is they would
attach
um like a like a a boy
to the surface and then they would
attach a rope
to the submarine and then the submarine
would would descend
um right down to the bottom so 15 1600
feet to the bottom
and then they would on the surface they
would follow this boy
um as it went along so that was if you
think about jaws that's effective what
it was like when that would be fired
the barrels into the into the great
white that's effectively what they were
doing with the submarine
and so they go down to the bottom they
spend
eight or nine hours on the on the bottom
um digging this little trench and
watching the cable drop in
and they had a tape recorder down there
and roger when he was down the roger
mallinson
like to listen to now this was 1973 so
this is the year of um
pink floyd dark side of the moon there
was all sorts of great albums released
in 1973. roger madison liked to listen
to to mozart and back's
um um organ music
he always insisted that the sound
because of the sphere
the sound inside the submarine was was
fantastic
and that's what he used to listen to he
was like he is an eccentric character
roger like a great man
and so the two of them were down there
and then after about eight or nine hours
they they um rose to the surface
and then what happened was a a big fluke
they get to the surface and then the
the team that come out on a little craft
and
they tow it they begin to tow it back in
but what happens is
a rope is that used to tow them it knots
over
the back of this the submarine um and
then the rope
knots around a bolt on the aft sphere
which is that which is at
the back of the submarine and
unfortunately
that's not covered and the bolt is
tightened
and the pressure inside the the a sphere
it basically flips open
so suddenly they're on the surface and
the aft
sphere which is the back of the the
submarine which is not connected
although it's although it's part of the
submarine
there's no um there's it's solids
effectively between that and the actual
compartment where the men are
but what happens is a ton of water
suddenly floods into the back of the the
atmosphere
so the submarine is incredibly
overweighted
and immediately begins to tip but first
and begins to sink down
now the key point here is that before
this happened they disconnected the boy
um so the the the the boy that told them
where the submarine was had been
disconnected the position mark is no
longer there
exactly exactly so the submarine falls
first first of all it drops to 160 feet
which is where the the end of the two
rope is so the two rob catches it
but they know there's no way the toe
rope can withstand the weight
so roger and allinson and roger chapman
and
are desperately trying to to drop to to
drop a
heavy weight that's attached to the
submarine to try and lighten the load to
buy themselves a bit more time
let's talk of a diver trying to get down
to to
attach a rope to it but then what
happens is
just as they've managed to get this
weight off there's a massive
crack and the the weight drops but also
the rope
snaps and suddenly they're plummeting um
right down to the bottom and roger
talked about how the
the water been driving through the
engines sounded like a sticker dive
bomber
so the plummeting down um roger
they're trying to get everything out of
the way because they know they're going
to crash land on the bottom
um roger tells them to start if roger
manson
remembers that is just in case they bite
their tongue off with the impact
they stuff rags in their mouth um and
then
they finally hit the bottom what sort of
speeds are they going when they do that
well it's about i mean it's a good
question
initially they thought it would be like
stuff you know 20 to 30 miles an hour
but i'm not sure it was
it was it was as fast as that and it was
certainly enough that they were they
were fearful that
it could it could crack open but what
happens is they smash down onto the onto
the bottom
and suddenly they're in pitch darkness
um and
initially they were waiting thinking so
they knew they were on the bottom
and they knew they were deeper than any
other submarine they'd been rescued
and and the first thing they were
fearful of was
a was the cracks in the submarine um so
they check there's no cracks in the
submarine
the next thing they're fearful of is
that although they know they have
they have oxygen supply down there the
key problem in a submarine
is effectively not the oxygen you're
breathing in but the carbon dioxide that
you're breathing out
so they know that they have a scrubber
which is effectively like a little
electric motor
which scrubs out the the oxygen it sucks
the oxygen
in scrubs it takes out the carbon
dioxide and then they bleed in
oxygen back into the chamber so it
maintains a safe
atmosphere effectively but they can only
do that
if the batteries are working and also
they're fearful that
if there's a problem with one of the
fuses or the cables on the battery
that it could ignite um and obviously
there had been the fire on board
um one of the apollo missions just a few
years previous time but that's a major
concern that
they could trigger a fire one of the
wires could have been
broken during the fall or something like
that exactly exactly and
they could trigger a fire inside and
then you know they're gone
weren't they only a small distance from
some
huge ledge in the sea floor that would
have dropped them down to some
insane depth well that was the that was
the consider they were they thought they
were maybe within a half a mile or a
mile of that but they didn't know how
far they
did they drifted because that was the
key point was that there was that kind
of the current was quite strong and they
were drifting as they fell
so yeah the concern was when they were
falling they were looking at the the
the debt going up 100 200 300 400 500
and they didn't know that they knew that
they were their deepest they were at
1700 feet when they were operating
and they thought had they gone deeper
than that then they would have been and
i mean i think we dropped down to about
three thousand feet
um but you know one break that didn't
happen
but they are when they they realize
what's happening
they're they're at you know 60 and 50
feet um
and i mean that the way i'd as i said
described it was trying to imagine that
you're in a phone box
next to the empire state building um and
then the atlantic ocean sweeps in
then all the lights go out then you
start bleeding oxygen
then you know that rescue is at least
two days away um and what you've got to
do is preserve your oxygen as long as
you can
why do they know that it's at least two
days away
because this is the problem and this is
what what makes it the rescue
um such an incredible feat above them is
vicar's voyager
and the only way that they can be
rescued is for
a diver can't get down to that depth so
the only way
is for another submarine to get down to
that depth and attach a rescue rope
now the submarines that are capable of
doing that is pat is pisces 2
which is in the north sea pisces 5
which is an um canada
and also the curve which is run by the
us navy which is a remote controlled
um miniature submarine which had been
used a number of years before and maybe
four or five years before
to pick up an a-bomb which which um
there had been a plane crash
above spain one of these bombs had
dropped and off the spanish coast
and it was a curve that had been sent
down to finally find the submarine
that that's not fine so i mean find the
bomb and bring it to the surface
so as they're sitting there they know
that the only thing that can rescue them
is a submarine which is either the north
sea canada
or the united states um and that the
submarine so the
the safety vessel above them the vicus
voyager that has to leave them
go back to cork and to pick up these
teams
but effectively what happens is they're
on the there on the seabed
and then a massive international rescue
is put into
into operation and vickers
oceanic at the time was one of the
general managers there was was peter
misservery
he was ex-navy and he himself had been
stuck
in a in the submarine um 600 or so
600 feet down in vancouver doing a test
a few years before so he knew exactly
what they were going through
and at the time what they did was they
put in
a kind of a rescue operation which was
built in braces
and then belts again so they got the
submarines from the north sea
they got that on a on a another vessel
and they started steaming back into port
they contacted the canadians and said
we're going to have to get to get you
guys over
and what was great was that al trice who
who devised and invented effectively the
pisces
uh submarine he was he was actually in
in london at the time and so he was able
to take part in the rescue as well
but he contacted the the the canadians
were contacted
and they basically swung into action
they loaded everything up onto trucks
and contacted the canadian air force the
canadian air force said look
don't worry the paperwork we've got
hercules aircraft ready for you
and just whenever you can get to the the
airport we'll have this hercules ready
didn't what isn't it a sub smash or
something wasn't there like some
huge red button that somebody pressed
that marshalls the entire world's forces
to try and help
yeah yeah that was the royal navy
because of smash which is which is
basically there's a submarine in in
in trouble and all help is available
but effectively what was interesting was
it was that it was the
vicars the canadians and the americans
the americans were all based in san
diego so they did the same thing
they rushed to the raid loaded up um
two um here kill these aircrafts and
within
it was probably i think it was within 10
12 hours and
you've got these these hercules aircraft
one flying from san diego
one flying from um canada and
the other team arriving in from into
cork
so then what you have is uh vickers
the the venture on the on the surface
has to leave them um another fishing
vessel comes and stays on the point
because the point is
they don't know that as i've said in the
book they know roughly where they are i
they know there's a haystack they just
don't know where the needle is
and so the there's the vest because
they've lost that boy
they've lost yeah yeah yeah yeah so they
had to
to head back to cork and
um that's effectively where the the
voyager was was laden with with the two
submarines
so back down in the submarine what do
the rogers do
now they land there and then they decide
to test the batteries and
what are the resources they need to
balance what do they do now yeah well
effective what they do is they
they know that the scrubber's operating
so that they know that they can take the
carbon
um sorry the carbon dioxide out there
out the atmosphere
and um replace it with a kind of oxygen
so that's okay
and we've got to keep the batteries
going and they know that initially the
the way it was opera the way they
operated was
the oxygen they had down there if they
were acting normally
chatting moving about that would
probably last 30-35 hours
but the estimate was that if they just
lay down
remained as silent as possible i mean
this calm is possible
they could extend that till about 65 70
hours
which was they kind of roughly weighing
the operation to hope
i mean if they could get there they
figured they could get there within
maybe 50 hours so it was
incredibly stressful um and incredibly
tense
in a time when they need to specifically
be as calm
as possible low heart rate low breathing
rate absolutely
and roger manson always said that that
he if he had to be stuck in a submarine
with anyone
he was so glad it was roger chapman
because roger chapman was ex-navy
and both of them were terrified but both
of them had that
stiff british upper lip which is i'm
terrified but i'm fine
i'm absolutely fine and i'm going to
operate as if i'm fine
so they moved they were internalizing it
yeah yeah they moved the entire sort of
they feng shuied
the whole internal compartment around so
that
they only needed to move a tiny amount
to check on
the few different bits and pieces yeah
they moved what they could the effect
could because of the way they were the
way the submarine had landed which is
kind of
forced into the sand they had to move
their kind of benches um
around and then they reconfigured it
effectively so that they could fit
they removed the minimum amount as
possible um
so that it was just as easy as possible
for them how are they communicating with
the surface
well there's there's an underwater
telephone um which is effectively
what they used and what was interesting
about it was i mean it was very staticky
and very kind of you could hear but what
was
fascinating was that there was a lot of
poor poises and dolphins in the area
and the dolphins would would squeak and
they would as roger manson said you
would lose messages to the dolphins
because you know they would be making
this kind of noise and he didn't mind it
so much because he loved the dolphins um
but that was another another element of
it
but they could they could yeah it was
effectively like an underwater radio
um that was it was operating so they
had a timer thing right they were doing
something every half an hour tell us
about that yeah exactly
well effectively what they have
the best practice was effectively to
operate the scrubber every 30 minutes
and so that would take out the kind of
carbon dioxide from the
from the atmosphere and but what they
did was and they had a timer to do that
so that they would either if they fell
asleep or they would always do it the
timer would go off
but effectively what they did was they
in order to maintain the
the the scrubber so the chemicals they
could only replace
a certain amount of time um in order to
extend that
they started pushing it further and
further so in ideal situations they
would do every half hour
but sometimes they would do it they
would go an hour 90 minutes without
doing it in order to kind of
maintain the resources as long as
possible what were the
effects of being down there because i
imagine cold condensation
cold because well the the the the food
supplies were very limited
they had like one sandwich they had a
tin of corona lemonade they had a flask
a half a flask of coffee
they had some ships biscuits um and and
that was it what about water no water no
water
what yeah which is incredible but yeah
so what they started doing was that the
condensation that built up
on the edge of the submarine they would
run their hands down that and they would
kind of dab their lips
um that way so it was um
it was it was a tough environment half a
canister of
coffee uh was it like a cheese and plum
and sandwich or something
yeah yeah because because malinson had
jam sandwiches which he'd eaten
and then a a tin of lemonade yeah
and some condensation yeah yeah and
that's that i mean that's what you've
got for
um for for three days how long i mean
three days must be close
to the hydration limit for humans yeah
yeah i mean it was it
was something that they were they they
were yeah it was it was kind of tough
for them but they managed to get what
they could from the
um from the from the walls of the of the
submarine
okay so we've got we've got them down
there yeah they're
trying to stay as still as they can
every half an hour to every hour they're
waking up to
play around with the oxygen leak the
oxygen back in also scrub the co2 out
what's happening on the surface well on
this on the surface the first thing is
um a voyager finally gets another ship
to
maintain position on the surface then
voyager
sails 13 14 hours back to
cork and by that time the pisces
submarine that was in the north sea
has been brought over to cork they wait
for the
the pisces from canada to arrive by
hercules
they unload that they get that onto
um the the voyager and then what's
interesting two things are interesting
altrice is delayed
in getting over to cork and so the
captain of
voyager said we're not waiting for him
so they steal off and then what happens
is
trace has to be helicoptered out into
the into the
the atlantic and then lowered down onto
the
um onto voyager there's no helipad on
voyageur there's no helipad
on voyager they're lowered down but and
also what's happening is when i found
the logs from vickers voyager
from the vickers company there's a
lovely line but it says something like
12 30
altrice dropped full stop onto voyager
brackets gently
because it gave them the case they just
dropped them on but it was the practice
gently i really again that's the beauty
of when you're writing a book you find
these little pieces of paperwork
and um it gives you an indication of it
so what happened then was
the americans were delayed so the
americans because they were obviously
flying from the west coast
they were they were delayed so they get
in to cork about 10 hours
later and um they have to wait because
of the title
effect um the the their ship is put on
to another ship
and they are effectively they're they're
ten hours behind
um vicar voyager so voyager gets back
to the the the scene of the accident
on the late in the early hours of friday
morning
so they are there so 40 hours later they
are on the scene
and then effectively there's a great
line which says how do you make god
laugh and it's telling your plans and
because what happened was
uh miss every had an idea that they
would get to the point
and they would send down a sub the one
of the the pisces submarines
and they would hook them up get them to
the surface and eddie was they'd be up
by breakfast
so first thing goes wrong is they try
and um
get their out their um these kind of
inflatable crafts that the you know just
inflatable kind of red boat
that would take them out to that roughly
the site where they think that the boy
the submarine sinks but the first engine
doesn't work the second engine doesn't
work eventually they have to get another
engine sent over
and from one of the naval vessels um and
that's just to tow
out um the pisces crack
now they make a decision they're going
down with a a heavy
with a rope um bound onto
a kind of like a clamp like a claw
effectively
at the front of the pisces and they make
a decision that they want the rope to be
of a certain buoyancy
the idea being that it would float up
above them and would would be less
likely
to become entangled the problem is
that submarine goes down and it's
piloted by a great guy goddess darcy
and it goes down down down the problem
is the deeper it goes
the greater the buoyancy on the rope and
effectively what happens is we get down
to about 1300 feet
and the buoyancy of the rope the
tensioner on that starts pulling
on the claw and effectively go picked
about 1400 feet
and then it gives so not only does the
rope and with the hook
pull out of the claw but it mangles the
claw
so they're in a position where they no
longer have a rope
and they no longer have a working claw
on this submarine
the decision is made to send down the
submarine anyway in an attempt to try
and find
uh pisces but after a few hours a they
can't find it no
that's the other thing at some point
that that pisces that submarine
springs a leak or there's a tension on
board so
they have to go back up to the surface
so that's the first dive
which was deemed to be the idea would be
that it would be very successful
but that doesn't work so then they bring
on board the canadians so altruist and
his team and another pisces
submarine um they are towed out
and dive two goes down to the bottom
the problem is it gets down to the
bottom and it's there for eight hours
and it can't find pisces three how are
they doing that just sit
simply by sight shining by but no but by
sonar effectively so what happens is
they've got they've got sonar down there
and
um they're kind of trying they're
scanning they're twisting around and
they're scanning
trying to find it and at one point they
get a ping
but that but what what effectively is is
and when they look at the scale of it
they realize that they're they're one
mile away
so under the water and that distance
with that kind of parameter
it's you know it's difficult if you if
you if you you were maybe
five six seven hundred feet away it
would still be tough to find it to get
it to the point where you could actually
illuminate it
and so they're down there for for eight
hours
no luck they go back to the surface um
at this point
the claws being worked on in the other
submarine they go back down again
and what they do is they get um roger
chapman to sing
at one point chapman's singing this
made-up song in the hope
that they can um hear them um the idea
because the higher notes might help
so chapman's singing away and um they
get the team
in the in the canadian submarine um are
are desperately trying to sort of you
know find exactly the right spot
and eventually they what is a
combination of of both malenson and
chapman
hearing a directional change on on on
their kind of underwater telephone so
there's a combination of them thinking
they've made some kind of change in the
canadians
uh ship and the canadians thinking right
we've locked on to them
can they communicate with the canadians
yeah well this is a thing
they can at some point it's um and
because at one point um
chap malinson's keeps keeps um
keeps talking and the canadians at one
point saying quiet please quiet please
and madison starts getting pissed off
pardon the language and because of this
is this is what's what's happened
and the other thing that annoys the
chapman in madison is that the canadians
are talking about meters and these guys
are saying well
what you know that we're dealing in feet
here we have to deal with we have to
deal in feet so it's like the old world
in the new world
kind of clashing and so eventually at
one point
they finally realize they'll lock on to
where they think they are
and malinson is looking up at the
porthole
and which is almost like a skylight at
that point because the way the position
the submarines
is facing and what they're looking for
is they're looking out into just a wash
of blackness
um but what they're waiting for is is
for light to come because the idea of
being that
the other submarine has has lights on it
and if
if they basically if the blackness out
there starts to illuminate
then they know they're going to be found
so eventually what happens is
they see the light in the water and they
realize that
um pisces fire that the canadians have
found them
and they think fantastic so what happens
is
the canadians position their their
submarine really close to pisces
and what they're trying to do is they've
got a device
that they're trying to hook on to onto
the the top of the rope
so the top of the of the submarine and
um they position it with their hook and
as described in the book it's
effectively like threading a needle
wearing a suit of armor
and but they've done it before they're
good at it this is what they do
but what happens is they put the hook
into the into the eye at the top of
pisces
three and they think they've locked on
so
for a second effectively they've got
this this rope
with the lifting strength to get them up
and
it's locked on but then in a again a one
in a thousand
misfortune it just falls out it spins
round effectively
and drop and drops out of sight so
there's a situation where they have to
spin round the submarine which bangs
pisces three
and they're trying to chase this rope as
it drifts away
and as i've said it's like it's like a
pensioner's race because the rope is
just
drifting very slowly a balloon caught in
a breeze
but they can only move very slowly and
they're desperately trying to kind of
catch it before it goes away
because if it drifts out of out of arm
reach effective or they miss it
they're going to have to go back to the
surface which is which is a few hours
find it retool get back down again the
bottom line is they get down
but the problem is they can't get it
back onto the lift point the only thing
they can do is fit it onto
a grille which is over one of the
propellers which
a allows them to know exactly where the
submarine is
but won't support the weight oh so they
would use that
as kind of like a minotaur's maze
way to follow it down it might not have
the boy attached to the top
but all that you would do in future is
now send a submarine okay just track
with this in sight down down down down
down but the problem is but
but the major problem is it doesn't it
won't support the weight of the
submarine so they can't lift
what about the roger and roger at the
moment have they not needed to go to the
bathroom have they not
i mean it's not it's not pretty but in
the book we have to describe how
how they have to go to the toilet which
is effectively just you know i mean
they're
without being too fine a point of it is
defecating in a plastic bag
and then putting the the bag inside that
kind of a
sealed metal biscuit tint um
didn't one of the lads have the runs as
well hadn't you had a bad pie or
something
yeah well that was it he'd been he'd be
constipated for a while and it just
could hold on no longer
but as he said afterwards the relief
afterwards was
was overwhelming um so that's what
that's
where they are the canadians have found
them but
the canadians eventually have to go back
up how many hours in are we
here oh we're about 50 hours 55
you know i mean they're they're they're
getting very close to the wire
and so then what happens is there's a
there's a third
trip down to try and get another another
rope on it doesn't work
um is that another pisces that time
that's another pisces trip down um so
but basically what happens is by by the
friday night
and they know that by saturday lunchtime
they're they're out of oxygen
by friday night and they still don't
have a working lift line on
and then what's what there's this great
sequence whereby um
you've got people like ted carter ted
carter is in barrow and furness
and ted carter is a kind of you know
assistant technical manager and he's
communicating with voyager on the on the
radio
and he realizes that they are despondent
that they are exhausted
and that isn't the rescue is not
happening the way it should be
so he just he decides that they should
send out another team
of kind of fresh men and he speaks to
leonard redshaw leonard redshaw was
known as mr polaris because he
effectively
worked with the navy to design the
player submarine he was like a real
he was the you know britain shipbuilder
effectively and he was in charge of
vickers
and his idea was we throw everything at
this kind of rescue mission
so he spoke to it to leonard rachel and
richard said yeah great put together a
team
so what happened is you've got this kind
of like dirty dozen
mission whereby um so
ted puts together a team of afghan men
give engineers divers
five of them they are flown in the in
the the
small private plane that vicars have
over to cork
and the royal navy have got permission
to fly into survivor's airspace nowadays
have been very supportive of it
they touch down at corki airport they
run across the the
the tarmac and they're loaded onto a
seeking um helicopter
problem is um the helicopter's going to
fly 150 miles out
and there's a storm so the weather's
atrocious none of these guys have been
on a helicopter before
um and so they're and what happens is
they fly out in the storm and is one of
the guys i was speaking to about it said
when they looked out they all they could
see was white they thought it was snow
but it was the tops of the waves
just being whipped up by by the weather
and
they are kind of 9 10 at night they're
lowered down
in the midst of this storm onto the deck
of voyager which is thrashing about
and what happens is they get lowered
down one at a time but every time
they're about to touch the deck
the the voyager sinks into a wave so
they
they think they're about to touch the
ground but the ground just falls
underneath them
and it's just this kind of amazing piece
of piloting in fact the pilot had
got in touch with me after after the the
book came out and and he was
commended and you know is for the
piloting that was involved in that and
keeping it steady
and lowering these men down so ted gets
down there
with his team um on the friday evening
and
he helps fix one of the submarines and
he goes down with dez darcy
um to on the kind of early hours of
saturday morning and it's ted
effectively who this guy who wasn't in
bahrain for nest
um sort of you know 12 hours before who
who helps get the first
actual lift line they developed a toggle
which is effective like an upside down
um umbrella and the idea would be that
this would be fitted into the atmosphere
and like a t-bar it would open out once
it was in
and and they managed to get the first
one in
um but at the same time the americans
had got out there finally um
and the what again
how do you make god laugh telling your
plans the idea was that they would
launch first
that they had this high technology for
1973
and remote controlled um the submarine
effectively it was like
as they said it was like a dog in alicia
well-trained dog in a leash
that would that could be sent down and
had cctv cameras
fixed on it um and that was supposed to
launch
about 11 at night on the friday night
and just as they're about to to power it
up it's a massive kind of
power grid for it what they didn't
appreciate was when they'd been wiring
all up
on the journey out salt water and sea
spray had contaminated all the circuits
so as soon as they pressed it up as soon
as effectively they powered up
the whole thing just blew so
again there's you know submarines aren't
working on on voyager
the americans are supposed to come and
rescue everyone buying
the blue and it was going to take four
hours to rewire the entire system
with everyone working at once um and
again
it's that kind of system where whereby
because they had so many resources out
there granted every system had its own
problems
what happened was um ted goes down and
pisces
gets that lift line attached but they
realize that they need another lift line
one is not going to be enough ones it
could potentially be enough but it's too
heavy to risk
it they want to get another because if
they drop it a second time yeah that's
it
they've literally got one chance with a
lift
so what they do is the the americans are
finally brought in on about
four five in the morning and what's
fantastic is after
everything that's gone wrong with every
other attempt
the americans goes absolutely like sil
it goes like clockwork
the curve is piloted down by larry brady
who who sadly just died a couple of
weeks ago
and but he pilots it um i brings it down
and drops off the another toggle into
the atmosphere
and as he described it to me he said it
was like it was like parking the car
after a very very long drive and i drive
of effectively three days um with but it
just goes that smoothly
so by 10 o'clock in the morning with
they've got maybe
they estimate they've got a few hours of
oxygen left but potentially less no
one's got
it has an absolute accurate account of
how much oxygen is left
they're in the position where they're
going to lift what is what does roger
and roger
like at this stage what sort of
physiological state are they in
well they're exhausted they're stressed
they're imagining the worst because
malinson's is both they're both amazing
guys but kind of malinson really knows
the submarine and he's
he's constantly overthinking what they
should be doing and trying to second
guess it
and chapman's the one who's trying to
sort of then you know cameron down just
saying look there's
chapman's attitude there's nothing we
can do here but effectively try and be
silent and breathe as little as possible
whereas marlinson is effectively trying
to second-guess and make suggestions
about what he can do and really try and
work out it so when it becomes to
to time to lift the submarine they are
both
internalizing it but as they admitted
afterwards
terrified because in their heads they
can't quite grasp
what the toggle is they think it's a
hook and they
they're constantly worried that like a
fish in a hook the fish is going to come
off the off the hook
and initially what happens is when they
start to lift
it there's something has been dragged
along the surface
um and it's only after a certain point
that it starts to lift up
but until it gets to the plum straight
line right below wherever it is
it's left it's lifted up and as they
said later on
the worst part of the entire experience
was the lift
was those final two hours because what
happened was that it was being lifted
from a different ship
this time they transferred over to a
kind of larger vessel
that was going to work we thought that
was actually operating where curved the
americans had been operating from
and what they did was they kind of moved
over um
to the the um the john cabot that was it
was the canadian coast guard it was an
icebreaker that they were moving off
from
that they were they or to operate the
lift from
and what happened was that because of
the stormy weather
this icebreaker was constantly being
forced up and down
20-30 feet because of the waves so if
you imagine you're fishing and you've
got a fish at the end of the hook
but that that fish is a submarine it's
constantly going up and down and it's
pivoting as it goes up
so it was like a really violent roller
coaster for them
and they're terrified because every move
every motion of the submarine
they're smashing about inside but they
also think that the hooks are going to
come off
and they're going to plummet down to the
bottom
also communication's breaking up so one
point they're shouting from to stop the
left they can't
get it to stop the other guys think they
want to continue there's a lot of
confusion
and then they stop at one point when the
curve which is the kind of american
system
that submarine is has wrapped around at
one point
with pisces so that they're lifting both
at once
um it all gets very confusing and very
kind of stressful
but at one point um they stop and that's
because they get about
120 feet from the surface and mess of a
decides we've got to get another line on
there once it gets the surface it's
going to get heavier
so there's a great situation where they
send down the divers
to try and attach another another rope
to it and it's bob um
bob hanley bob hanley is sent down as a
diver with one of his colleagues
with a hook and the idea is as he
describe it is trying to land on a
bucking bronco
so the submarine itself is thrashing
about moving up and down
and he's got to time his dive so that he
can
land on it and and effectively straddle
it like you would a bucking bronco
while it's moving up and down with the
waves at the top
and he's holding a uh at the rope
with this kind of um hook that he's
trying to
wage and in fact that's not it what it
is it's a
it's a a really thick rope attached to a
u-curve
with a bolt attached to it and the
bolt's attached to a string
and what he has to do is he has to get
the u-bend of the of the metal
substantially
under um the top of the submarine then
he has to screw in a bolt
like like a carabiner to sort of close
off the opening yeah
exactly exactly um and all while
under water 120 feet on a submarine this
thrashing about
and it's an incredibly tense moment but
he manages to get it on
and um they effectively send down
another rope
um and it's over in a position where
there's all these three ropes
pulling up and finally um they make it
to the surface
with yeah and a very tense moment
okay so they get to the surface and then
there's still complications then right
like getting the
the hatch open and yeah yeah balance
always remembers that
he just they were they bled in more
oxygen
when did they eat the sandwich well good
question i think they ate
at some point but they certainly they
celebrated with they cracked open the
the corona lemonade as soon as they were
found that was their dealers that they
wouldn't
open the lemonade until they were found
so they cracked open the lemonade then
and as manson said remember because of
him they'd be going on it can taste like
[ __ ]
you know but you know [ __ ] never tasted
too so sweet and given that given the
conditions they were in
um but when they got to the surface they
were
uh manson remembers it very vividly he
just they couldn't get the
actual um hatch open so he was kind of
kicking it
um and lying on the bottom and kicking
the surface of the
even the hatch even though they're at
the surface this doesn't give them any
more oxygen or any more co2 scrubbing
right you could be
sealed in on the top of everest and it
would be precisely the same as being at
the bottom of the ocean
exactly exactly they've got to get that
hatch open to get fresh air in
finally bang the kind of hatches the
hatches open and as there's a lovely
moment where effectively they said that
they had
the first argument of the whole time
they were down there
what was then when the hatch was open
malinson was the pilot
and malinson's argument was that he
should be the last person out because
he's pilot he's responsible for the
craft
chapman is much wiser because they're in
a storm you know
the waves are thrashing about and as
chapman um says to marlin
it says to roger roger you can't swim
so that was his argument the heat that
the the the malinson should be the first
person out of the submarine
on the grounds that if water floods in
at least chapman um
can swim because matt mountain's never
never learned to swim
um so eventually they finally get they
get them out um and
you know it's yeah and what's very
touching is that
i when i was just reading the book to
people and i was writing about the book
what they've been arrested by this idea
of the brotherhood of the sea
all these other vessels had come to
their aid men had come from canada
from california from the north sea from
ireland
everyone had pulled together and for
this a three-day period the kind of
world was waiting
you know with baited breath to find out
could these men be
be rescued it was akin to the situation
a couple of years back with the
with the school party trapped in the
cave um and that kind of thing thailand
it was
um where you're waiting to see could
they could they be rescued and they were
rescued
but for the men on board who toiled for
so long on vicar's voyage
they were on the on the edge of the ship
looking out
and when they saw the surf that the sub
hit the surface and finally see these
guys climb out
you know there was people just brushed
into tears and these were men who'd
never you know as i'd said their eyes
had been parched for decades
you know they just didn't cry about
anything but it was just the
overwhelming
emotion of of willing something to
happen and for so many things to go
wrong
and they finally they finally got them
to the surface and listen
and that was part of the reason why i
wanted to write the book was was
obviously there was the experience of
the men on board
but it was also to capture all these
characters who'd been
who've endangered being lost to history
you know like kind of altrice like ted
carter bob hanley all these people
who you guys would have devised the the
toggles
um and you know when you speak to ted
carter today and he's very blase about
it he just said he helps
you know but it's you you they did they
did remarkable things
uh larry brady and in california so
that was it it was everyone had pulled
together to pull off this incredible
rescue
and when you consider everything that
had gone wrong even to the point where
at one point they needed new rope and
the
the navy who were out there um ferried
rope across
um a kind of wired basket effectively
underneath a helicopter
but they misjudged the weight of the
rope so as soon as the helicopter took
off and started flying toward
uh voyager and they could see the
helicopter immediately
start being being dragged down to the to
the sea so they suddenly
the hell got to pilot to jettison the
rope and um
suddenly the rope's tumbling down and
altrice is on the deck of voyager with
peter miss everybody looking out at the
rope they're supposed to get
and suddenly the rope's just bobbing
across the surface of the atlantic
and i'll try to the motto that he used
to used to say
and his attitude was well if it was easy
everyone would do it
and this was a rescue that was far from
easy how close to the wire was it with
resources and oxygen and well it's
complicated because
because afterwards if you see if you see
there's a little fuji of them on youtube
talking about when they finally touch
down on them on on korg
and they're very stiff upper lip british
everything's fine always plenty of
resources
it was very comfortable at one point
they say on this on on the bottom
and it was very comfortable um and the
report was that they could have gone for
a number of hours afterwards
however the people i spoke to um who who
had first had the experience of it one
of them said that
it was his job to to inspect the
submarine
when it was finally brought back to cork
and he was on but on he went
into the submarine with the the kind of
u.s kind of um
um authority his job is to monitor
safety for submarines
and they said he remembers two things
very vividly one was
the stench of the place the stench of
the submarine
and the second thing was that when they
turned on the oxygen
just nothing came out his attitude was
that they were just absolutely down to
the wire
minutes yeah yeah you know we'll never
know exactly
how much it's this two to to complete
his power back to tale but his attitude
was that there was there was nothing
left
yeah the video of the rogers talking
about it wasn't doesn't one of them say
what was the worst part of it and he
said coming back up
yes yeah and i think that's because a
lot of what they say is very much you
know that can stiff up our of our
british lip saying it's it's fine and
you have to
knowing what having put together the
book knowing what preceded it
we can now understand why that was
because it was i mean
they're being rescued but it took two
hours to get them to the surface
and they were being smashed about for a
good chunk of that and when they weren't
being smashed about
they were hanging like a like a fish in
a hook unaware
what was happening and all the time they
know that at the very limit
of of what oxygen is left so
it's that thing where when you look at
all the components that had to be in
place for them to be rescued
the curve being flown over from
california
the pisces flying over from halifax the
team coming over from the north sea
and when you look at all the things that
went wrong you all you have to think
about is another link in that chain
being delayed or another problem or
something that you know like
imagine it took it was four hours to fix
the curve
um electrics to get the sub down imagine
it took four and a half
or five i mean they were that close
because it wasn't that case of
it took a long time to get for the
rescue to begin and then the rescue went
really smoothly
literally everything that could have
gone wrong with the rescue did go wrong
but they still managed to get them up
and that was it's not gonna it's that
great line from winston churchill never
ever ever give up
and i think that this rescue is a
testament to that what did the guys do
after this did they go back to the sea
did any of them descend again
yeah both of them but within within a
few weeks they were they were back in
the submarine
yeah absolutely well marlinson's
attitude was you know he
you know it was there was errors but you
wanted to get back on to the submarine
and chapman did it for a spell but then
chapman used his experiences
to set up a company that's that that
developed um
rescue for submarines so so chapman went
on to
to take his experience and turn it into
a very successful business
and that was involved and the that was
called upon but not used tragically for
the kirk
disaster but then was called upon to
rescue another
um russian submarine um you know in the
you know
i think it was 10 12 years ago so um
yeah he had an amazing experience from
it
commercialized his catastrophe yeah
absolutely but what was what was very
very special about it was the the bond
between the two remained
up until i mean um roger chapman sadly
died
a year ago in january i think it was um
but up until that up until the the
september before
on the day of the rescue marlinson would
phone him at the same at the
the exact moment they were rescued just
after one o'clock on the anniversary
and then afterwards at a certain point
they would meet for lunch on that day
every year so there was like a very
close bond
that existed as a consequence of the
rescue and their experiences down there
in the deep
did you get to speak to them um i got to
speak to mountain a lot and but sadly
roger chapman had
died before i began researching the book
um but i spoke to his widow june chapman
who was very supportive and his
and his two sons who were very
supportive and and interviewed manson a
lot for the book along with the as many
as the rescuers
who were who were still alive so it was
a great pleasure to
to speak to them and to also to feel
like to try and effectively illuminate
this story which has been
been largely forgotten but it is an
incredible tale of of heroin
and also that element of of what you can
do if a team pulls together
there's something sort of especially
nostalgic and kind of beautiful about it
because as you say it was the analog age
probably just toward the end of it
but if uh yeah go ahead no it's
interesting to see that when i was
researching the book
i discovered that um this was 73 when
the contact cable
was late and as i said 175 phone calls
could be making any point
but in that same year the first mobile
phone call was made
and it was by by one developer to
another to his competitor effectively to
say that he was
that they were ahead of the game and and
it's one of these regrets actually i
didn't use it as a footnote somewhere
because it was effective i just couldn't
like the touch of that so
there was it was it wasn't analog age
but it was also the year that
the future i mean the future would be
here effectively but there was that kind
of nice touch but yeah i mean it was
this was this is men in boiler suits
with t-squares
um trying to fix things so i mean even
the device the toggle that rescued them
i mean that was designed on paper with
t-squares and manufactured in a few
hours
in fact a nice touch that would appeal
to an alien comedy
when they went over to the fabrication
unit having designed this rescue toggle
they spoke to the foreman and said we've
got to made this build and he looked and
said yeah look we can start it next week
um and he said no no that we did this so
he put him on to leonard
redshaw and richoff and no one certain
terms told them that it would be made
today
in fact this afternoon and they said
right why didn't you say so they
they made it in the space for a few
hours didn't the queen contact the guys
at one point
well that was the great thing they get a
message um
garbled down from the phone that that
queen elizabeth
is is thinking well of you and now and
this was very moving to them
because um chapman had served in the
royal navy so you serve
you serve her majesty effectively and
malinson was also deeply with this idea
that
at this hour they are kind of you know
darkest hour the queen the monarch you
know
britannia effectively was thinking well
of them and it kept them going
but it was only until they got to the
surface a couple of days later that what
it was was it was the qe2
had been steaming past and had offered
to assist
but that system wasn't required but they
said look wish the men well
so it wasn't the queen at all no it
wasn't the queen it was the qe2
but but the message that they got and
they helped sustain them was that it was
the queen herself
that was that was wishing them well so
it's best they didn't know
i'm sure that she would have done as
well yeah the the video
of the guys coming out and the interview
with them afterward
is peak hard british guy
from sort of the mid 1900s it was
mostly fine down there we could have
survived for another
you know another day also it was yeah
yeah oh it's it's
um i suppose that's what's fascinating
about it is that kind of age where
um you you mean okay
what was interesting about is they both
gave quite moving interviews one to the
telegraph one to the mail about a week
or so later
but it was that it's not the days where
um people it's effectively kind of
the cameras brought out please emote and
please emote copiously
um it wasn't like that at all it was it
was how it was that very british thing
of
um i've gone through the greatest trauma
of my life but how do i minimize it
um yeah exactly yes yes
um but that's the benefit of of of of
putting together a book like the dive
whereby you can
you can lay out only effectively when
you you lay out chronologically
in as much detail as i've been able to
do where you show
everything going wrong and and then
what's put in
in place to to rectify that and even
remarkable people like as i say kind of
ted carter i spoke to him about it so
his i mean
he was down in the submarine everything
had gone wrong
his his colleagues lives are effectively
literally in his hands because he's the
man who's
who's manipulating this toggle and he
has to get it in
and i asked him about the pressure of
that in the book i refer to the fact
that i mean
there's like 50 tons of pressure from
bearing down on the submarine but
internally there should be the same
amount bearing down on him
but he was very blasey about it you know
he just said
some people just built that way that
they're very under under at times of
great crisis they are they can be
very relaxed and very focused and he was
one of those kind of characters whereby
he had a job to do he managed to get it
done right
for the job yeah and saved and saved his
colleagues life along with
the rest of the team amazing man that's
such a fascinating story i think you've
done an awesome job with the book
that'll be linked to the dive will be
linked on amazon below any other
bits if people want to learn more about
this yeah well
yeah well yeah yeah just buy it but buy
the dive
and that that's the best way to do it um
but i mean it's a it is a fascinating
story
and also what i was glad because and
also in the book i tell the story of
well there's a section where i talk
about the development submarines but
also
the the lane of the cable back in the
king of 1850s and 60s
um this great kind of nautical journey
to try and
connect the old world and the new is
quite an amazing story and they were
this little part of it
further down the line but it's no it's i
mean i'm i'm i'm i hope people will read
it because it's
it is one of those situations whereby um
it's just the ability of people not
giving in and
and a team of of a team of men and
rescuing their colleagues
beautiful story steve mcginty ladies and
gentlemen thanks so much for the time
nope thank you very much thank you very
much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace